at 6 34 housing remains a real big
concern for local domestic violence
centers a survey of 13 Nevada
non-profits found housing is the biggest
unmet need Candace Charles is live this
morning at safe nest with what experts
say really needs to be done Candace good
morning
yeah well safeness was one of those 13
domestic violence Dentures to
participate in the voluntary survey and
really funding is the big thing that
could turn this all around now the
national network to end domestic
violence conducts the survey every year
2022 was its 17th annual 13 out of 18 of
the reported domestic violence centers
participated in the census the census
provides a point in time for a
non-invasive unduplicated record of
people who access domestic violence
Services during a single 24-hour period
the Nevada DV centers get housing
funding from HUD and about one percent
from the violence against women act
housing remains a huge concern Safe
House provides about 30 to 40 beds safe
nests 130 so for a county of 2.4 million
people there are less than 200 beds for
domestic violence victims and survivors
DVD Survivor Advocates say American
Rescue plan funding could help
we know that housing lists are long
across the country domestic violence
programs have had funding cut for
housing over the years we have one-time
inflow of money this is an opportunity
to use that in a way that is really
critical for our most vulnerable
population
last year about 291 people were able to
get some emergency housing assistance
both transitional and emergency housing
is badly needed here in Nevada and it
could be determining Factor if a victim
returns to their abusers so if you'd
like to help you can reach out to your
legislators if you do need assistance
you can go to safenest they have a
24-hour emergency hotline at
702-646-4981 we'll have those details on
our website 8newsnow.com for now live
from the safe Nest donation center I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now